[Musique]
bienvenue au Parlement européen de
Bruxelles pour ce nouveau numéro de la
faute alors il y a un secteur en Europe
qui est pas toujours pris au sérieux et
qui passe littéralement sous les radars
à Bruxelles alors que c'est un marché de
plus de 23 milliards d'euros par an ce
sont les jeux vidéos plus d'un Européen
sur deux joue au jeu vidéo à commencer
par Jean Quatremer sur ce plateau en
France il y a 37 millions de joueurs
l'industrie européenne est très
compétitive et ses pépites suscitent les
appétits chinois et puis évidemment
américain alors quelle stratégie
économique pour les jeux vidéo mais
surtout c'est un outil d'influence de
soft power les autres puissances l'ont
bien compris a commencé par les Russes
et aussi les Chinois qui s'en servent
comme un outil d'ingérence étrangère de
manipulation le Parlement européen où
nous trouvons a récemment voté une
résolution sur les jeux vidéo et son
auteur Laurence Farin dépité européenne
Rignoux Renaissance est avec nous
bonjour Madame nous avons également l'un
des grands acteurs français du secteur
Fabrice la rue bonjour Fabrice la rue
vous êtes le président de focus
Entertainment c'est donc une des grosses
boîtes éditeurs de jeux qui représente
170 millions de chiffre d'affaires par
an absolument bon qui est très bien et
sur Rennes et vous allez pouvoir donc
avec vous deux on aura la dimension
législative européenne et la dimension
industrielle également avec nous
Clotilde Goujard de politico et Jean
Quatremer de libération vous jouez
plutôt à quel jeu moi j'en suis alors là
mais c'est un monde qui met totalement
étranger parce que j'ai passé mon temps
à lutter contre mes enfants qui jouaient
à des jeux vidéo très bien voilà mais
c'est pour ça que maintenant à Bruxelles
les jeux vidéo sont sous les radars vu
le nombre de ringards qu'on a ici on
fait un point avec Julien gaspardieu il
le prend bien on le voit pas à l'antenne
mais quand j'ai parlé de ringard mais il
le prend bien on fait un point sur ce
dossier avec Julien Gasparetto le
correspondent français vision à
Bruxelles
c'est une première en novembre dernier
les députés européens ont voté une
résolution appelant à renforcer les
investissements dans les jeux vidéo dans
cette résolution les députés appellent à
reconnaître la propriété intellectuelle
européenne à faciliter l'accès aux
compétences numériques à soutenir les
petits studios et puis aussi à se
pencher sur la pratique croissante de
l'esport le sport numérique
l'objectif général est de définir un
cadre législatif pour les jeux vidéo un
secteur en constante progression avec
5000 studios en Europe qui génèrent près
de 100 000 emplois directs ou indirects
dont 15000 en France avec des structures
de référence comme Ubisoft mais faute de
stratégie européenne cette industrie
reste très fragile en proie des
investisseurs étrangers notamment
américains ou chinois et à une fuite des
talents européens vers ces pays en
parallèle les députés soulignent les
risques que peut engendrer la pratique
de certains jeux vidéo notamment chez
les jeunes et ils appellent à poursuivre
les régulations pour une meilleure
prévention enfin le phénomène est moins
connu mais les jeux vidéo sont aussi la
cible d'ingérence étrangères notamment
via les chats ou les messageries
interactives qui servent aussi à faire
passer des messages politiques alors
dans le contexte de guerre en Ukraine de
plus en plus de voix s'élèvent pour
appeler à redoubler de vigilance sur les
risques engendrés par ces ingérences
merci Julien gasparuto bon Laurence
Farin pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
voulu rédiger cette résolution ici au
Parlement européen parce que comme vous
l'avez dit le jeu vidéo et l'esport qui
est un autre phénomène d'importance sont
complètement sous les radars
électronique
n'existe pas dans les politiques
publiques européennes absolument pas
alors il faut dire que d'une part la
politique culturelle européenne est très
faible on sait que un seul programme qui
s'appelle Europe créative qui représente
0,2% du budget européen c'est déjà
indigent et dans cet ensemble déjà
pauvres le jeu européen existe à la
marge sur certains appels à projets donc
il était plus que temps de s'en occuper
moi je m'en suis rendu compte au moment
du covid parce que évidemment au moment
du covid dans ce moment où on était chez
soi le jeu vidéo comme les plateformes
d'ailleurs ont particulièrement explosé
avec gros une très très forte
progression et c'est ce qui m'a amené à
m'y intéresser
faut savoir que ce secteur il avait une
véritable richesse donc au delà des a
priori qu'on peut avoir sur le côté geek
les ados enfermés dans leur chambre il y
a un monde extrêmement riche c'est le
cinéma du 21e siècle c'est un art total
avec énormément de de compétences de
métiers d'art qui se lient du graphisme
à la musique et en touchant à la
dimension technologique et alors on
parle de souveraineté numérique et bien
le jeu vidéo est aussi une brique qui
peut nourrir les compétences qui peut
nourrir les les engagements et donc
voilà l'idée était de faire connaître la
richesse de ce secteur et d'inciter à
avoir une véritable stratégie européenne
en faveur du jeu vidéo c'est à dire
beaucoup de choses et notamment et
prioritairement des fonds et surtout à
la veille du métaverse exactement parce
que le jeu vidéo a inventé le métal
voilà Fabrice la rue les Européens
comment on s'en sort au niveau mondial
de l'industrie du jeux vidéo ah on est
petit on est petit comme vous rappeliez
le marché fait 23 milliards en Europe et
le marché fait 180 milliards dans le
monde donc on est petit et l'enjeu comme
la très bien dit Madame la député c'est
nous de construire des groupes européens
fortes face à la colonisation et la
technologie des gafanes ou l'arrivée de
gros industriels comme tennsen ou notice
des Chinois qui pèsent entre 50 et 150
milliards il faut qu'on construit des
groupes très forts c'est ce que nous on
essaye de faire la concurrence est très
difficile là-dessus mais le marché est
très porteur 180 milliards d'euros au
niveau mondial c'est devant c'est la
première industrie finalement c'est
devant la musique c'est devant le cinéma
on s'en rend pas forcément compte mais
aujourd'hui avec la covid on est passé à
95% digitalisés
donc maintenant tout est en ligne tout
est en ligne ça a marché quand même ou
c'est un tiers de la population mondiale
qui dépense 80 dollars par an donc c'est
énorme mais les jeux vidéo ils en
prenaient un autre qui est pas un
Français ni un Européen qui s'appelle
fortnite c'est plus un jeu vidéo il
diffuse des séries il diffuse des
concerts et diffuse des événements c'est
devenu un média les hommes politiques
qui font faire la promotion sur ce média
tu mets un média franco-français
européen c'est un média mondial c'est
une communauté de plusieurs centaines de
millions de personnes alors justement
fortnite en fait le jeu vidéo c'est
souvent donc une porte d'entrée pour
disséminer des discours de propagande et
c'est pas un phénomène nouveau déjà il y
a il y a trois ans Cédric Cousseau
interrogé le journaliste Paul conge qui
avait suivi des filières de recrutement
sur le jeu vidéo fortnite
par exemple j'ai suivi une mouvance
négationniste qui elle allait recruter
les jeunes directement dans le célèbre
jeu vidéo fortnite en allant voilà
alpager des jeunes pour essayer ensuite
de les tirer vers leurs espaces de
discussion des espaces de discussion
clos où on accepte par invitation et où
on discute on discute tout un tas de
sujets je suis à Montreuil et c'est un
mélange entre le Mali et le Sénégal les
seuls blancs sont des gauchistes de 40
kg
le lobby LGBT ne sera jamais majoritaire
l'islam si ils peuvent se soulever et
la merde bref moi je suis pour
une milice armée nationaliste ça serait
classé utile c'est dans ces dans ces
espaces là qui vont diffuser leurs idées
qui vont voilà fédérer une communauté
qui derrière sera mobilisable voilà
Laurence Farin il faut il faut lutter
aussi contre cette filière de
recrutement là en fait on retrouve toute
la problématique des réseaux sociaux
parce que comme le disait monsieur la
rue vous êtes sur des plateformes vous
êtes sur des plateformes de streaming
comme twitch ou en effet c'est des
plateformes ouvertes comme les autres
mais l'Union européenne a montré qu'elle
savait réguler on a le digital service
Isaac qui va s'appliquer complètement à
cette question donc on est dans la même
problématique quand
on peut aussi avoir des jeux avec des
des philosophies ou des idéologies un
peu borderline sur Steam là c'est pareil
on va avoir le DMA de DSA qui vont
pouvoir intervenir pour réguler tous ces
alors le DJ tel Market a été le digital
services actes qui vont bientôt entrer
en vigueur et qui vont des régulations
de tout ce qui se passe sur Internet
comme
folie comme dérive et comme un gérance
donc on a montré qu'on était capable
d'agir là-dessus pour autant ça doit pas
ternir l'image du jeu vidéo parce que
les dérives en ligne elles peuvent être
sur tous les supports et c'est un
support particulièrement riche parce
qu'ils ouvrent ils ouvrent à des
imaginaires mais là où il y a aussi un
point important c'est sur la question de
la souveraineté européenne du jeu vidéo
parce que et bien des jeux vidéo
proposés par exemple par la Chine
peuvent avoir une forme de censure
exemple le drapeau taiwanais qui
n'existe pas sur les jeux vidéo chinois
sur certains jeux vidéo chinois donc ça
c'est une autre manière vous parler de
de faire de l'influence et de
l'ingérance vous parliez de soft power
on a tout intérêt à garder nos pépites
nos gros jeux vidéo qui eux peuvent
porter ce qu'on appelle la valeur
ajouter européenne dans les industries
culturelles quand on parle de politique
européenne et qui peuvent diffuser
d'autres d'autres imaginaires encore une
fois vous sentez que les pépites
européennes sont un peu en danger ou en
tout cas que l'industrie européenne est
en danger face aux appétits des Chinois
et des Américains ou pas
aujourd'hui
nos jeux que nous produisons en Europe
puis sont vendus à plus de la moitié
aux États-Unis et un tiers en Europe et
pas plus de 5 à 6% en Asie parce que
comme disait madame si vous voulez aller
en Chine et des comités pour filtrer vos
jeux ils ne font pas vous rendre rentrés
pas vos jeux donc ils peuvent venir
vendre leur jeu en France ou en Europe
mais nous on peut pas aller en Asie donc
il y a un risque évidemment de
distribution de nos produits surtout que
je pense qu'en dehors du jeu comme le
disait madame la députée c'est qu'on a
une dimension éducative culturelle
sociétal et c'est devenu un ambassadeur
en France on a des très bons créatifs on
a des bons développeurs on est des bons
techniciens en c'est pareil il faut les
valoriser il n'y a pas que dans le luxe
on peut exporter notre savoir-faire
éducative culturelle mais aussi en
matière de défense c'est un vrai sujet
alors on a interrogé l'avocate Ophélie
omes qui est co-autrice du rapport
ingérence étrangère et jeux vidéo pour
le mouvement européen et le temps est-ce
qu'on a également constaté c'est que il
y a eu une croissante un croissant
intérêt de l'Union européenne pour la
question de l'ingérence il y a eu un
rapport en mars 2022 il y a eu cette
déclaration de Mercotte vestigeur en
novembre 2022 également sur l'Europe de
la défense qui doit être aussi une
Europe de la cyberdéfense on a
parallèlement l'Union européenne qui se
préoccupe du jeu vidéo qui se
rencontrent progressivement que le jeu
vidéo est un bien culturel en plus
d'être simplement un produit mais on a
encore du mal à concevoir le jeu vidéo
comme un bien politique voilà donc il y
a un véritable enjeu politique et j'ai
lu par exemple cette article dans Le
Canard enchaîné il y a quelques jours
Jean ça va vous intéresser sur les
stages
masculinistes qui consiste à survivre nu
dans la forêt le temps d'un week-end des
aventures initiatiques des nouveaux
guerriers avec vraiment cette apologie
de l'homme dominant et parmi les lieux
de recrutement vous avez vous riez mais
c'est une affaire sérieuse parmi les
lieux de recrutement d'accord pour ces
stages masculinistes jeux vidéo.com oui
Laurence parrain c'est un des idées
d'extrême droite sont des idées de vie
c'est un problème de ciblage on sait
qu'on va trouver peut-être un certain
type d'internautes jouant un certain
type de jeu donc on se dit c'est là
qu'on va les recruter donc d'où
l'important c'est voilà c'est du ciblage
en ligne donc je reviens à nos histoires
de régulation en ligne elles sont
d'autant plus inspirantes et importantes
de même que la transparence des
algorithmes du ciblage tout ça sont des
questions de régulation au niveau
numérique mais si on regarde le ciblage
donc ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que dans les jeux vidéo en Europe
c'est 100000 personnes à peu près et ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'alors que
c'est assez équilibré entre les hommes
et les femmes parmi les joueurs ceux qui
travaillent dans les jeux vidéos ce sont
essentiellement des hommes ça c'est un
souci aussi 20% 20% de femmes à peine ça
fait partie des enjeux du secteur c'est
que j'ai identifié dans le rapport
d'ailleurs c'est très masculin or comme
vous dites les joueuses sont à parité
donc il y a un très gros travail à faire
comme ça a été fait dans beaucoup de
secteurs mais c'est un secteur plus neuf
plus émergent pour attirer les jeunes
filles pour qu'elles se disent c'est
pour nous il y avait une question aussi
de représentation des femmes dans les
jeux vidéo qui n'étaient pas toujours
forcément très égalitaire paritaire on
avait toujours on a eu on a eu ces
représentations de femmes vues par des
hommes donc avec des attributs etc c'est
en train d'évoluer et c'est pour ça
qu'il fait aussi faire
confiance aux créatif à la création aux
femmes qui rentrent dans le secteur moi
j'ai visité des écoles où il y a de plus
en plus de femmes et les faire venir à
ça Fabrice la rue vous arrivez à trouver
des femmes à recruter des fans dans ce
secteur très difficile c'est vrai que le
jeu nativement était très masculin
notamment quand vous avez un joueur des
forces payer shooters
mais c'est le plus gros de marcher c'est
souvent des des hommes le recrutement
est très difficile dans ce métier et
surtout les femmes mais sont aussi
emploi nous on a tout un programme RSE
pour pouvoir former et développer ce
métier faire ce ses responsabilités
sociales de l'entreprise c'est ça
absolument
sachant que quel est le niveau de
financement de l'Union européenne dans
le dans le jeu vidéo la somme la somme
paraît dérisoire 5 millions d'euros par
an oui moi j'avais joui c'est à peu près
ça mais ça fait partie des si vous
voulez des appels à projets de Rob
créatif qui sont pas fous pour la
dernière une période d'Europe créative
je crois qu'il y avait 24 millions
d'euros sur la période de 7 ans donc ce
qui est rien du tout
c'est en progressant il y a un nouveau
dispositif qui a été lancé par Thierry
Breton à Cannes mais qui inclut quand
même le jeu vidéo qui s'appelle médias
invest et
d'investissement pour amorcer
l'investissement privé aussi sur le site
mais ce manque de financement c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des raisons pour
laquelle les géants chinois et
américains viennent en Europe et peuvent
si facilement prendre participation ou
acheter ses compagnies européennes qui
n'arrivent à un moment plus à survivre
et quand on leur parle à Gamescon ou
voilà en Allemagne il nous disait qu'il
y a un moment il se demande plus si
leurs propriétaires européens chinois ou
américain parce que s'il y a plus
d'investissement eux ils veulent
continuer à pouvoir créer à pouvoir
faire leur travail et donc ils se
tournent vers des Chinois comme Tencent
qui a pris les participations notamment
dans le géant français
Ubisoft donc
avec le deuxième studio de jeux vidéo
français aussi et ces énormes boîtes
chinoises continuent à apprendre de plus
en plus toutes ces petites boîtes ou
plus grosse boîte européenne très pleine
de promesses dans ce secteur bon
qu'est-ce que là je parle à l'industriel
qu'est-ce que l'Europe doit faire dans
ce domaine là qu'est-ce que vous dites
Fabrice la rue à Laurence Farah moi je
dis que réglementé c'est un peu défensif
il faut le faire mais quand j'entends 6
millions d'investissements c'est
vraiment pas à la hauteur des enjeux je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait des fonds
comme des fonds comme en France la BPI
ou des fonds souverains importants qui
accompagnent des industriels à
consolider ce secteur et remettre la
création des jeux au coeur d'un métier
industriel et réindustrialisé ce métier
donc il faut évidemment qu'on soit pas
uniquement défensif qu'on soit offensive
en créant des champions c'est-à-dire que
quand des petits studios doivent pas se
tourner une victoirement sur les Chinois
ou les Américains doivent se tourner sur
des industriels comme nous ou d'autres
Européens pour les consolider et les
aider à se développer alors laissant une
totale autonomie territorial et mais
qu'il puisse s'appuyer sur des
plateformes technologiques sur des
plateformes commerciales sur les
plateformes marketing pour les pour se
vendre à l'international problème Jean
c'est que au moment des arbitrages
financiers ici à Bruxelles quand on dit
bon où est-ce qu'on met l'argent il faut
investir dans la transition écologique
il faut investir dans la transition
énergétique
forcément les jeux vidéo ça arrive il
faut pas oublier que le fond de relance
par exemple de 750 milliards d'euros
avec votre vide post covid est prévue
quand même que 30% des investissements
qui devaient être fait devaient être
consacré à la transition numérique et le
jeu vidéo fait partie de cette
transition numérique et je vous rappelle
quand même que ce qui se passe en
Ukraine en ce moment montre une chose
c'est que la culture de du jeu vidéo et
bien a été utilisé par les militaires
Ukrainiens parce que on a découvert que
ces gens étaient extrêmement habitués on
pensait que ça serait une cyberguerre
mais vous savez avec des attaques des
Russes contre nos systèmes informatiques
c'est une cybergère mais pas du tout
comment on l'attendait c'est-à-dire on
des soldats Ukrainiens qui sont
extrêmement compétents qui savent
détourner effectivement ce qu'ils ont
appris avec des jeux vidéo utilisez donc
des drones etc etc et même des canons
Césars qui ont été détournés de leur de
leur fonctionnement pour pouvoir grâce
justement à cette culture du jeu vidéo
alors moi qui lutté contre le jeu vidéo
à la maison non-stop à mon fils je
commence à regretter vous avez des
biologies en tout cas Jean quatre-mères
qui manifeste des regrets tous les jours
c'est bien que c'est bien je pense qu'on
enregistre à vous faire une cassette de
ce qui vient de dire la technologie va
en tout cas provoquer des
bouleversements Jean vous n'êtes pas au
bout de vos peines et va retourner des
situations mais ça pourrait être dans le
bon sens à de vieux combats depuis des
années des combats qu'il pensait perdus
comme le multilinguisme mais
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
tomber à point nommer l'édito de Jean
Quatremer
dans l'un des épisodes de la série
télévisée Star Trek Discovery l'USS
Enterprise fait l'objet d'une
ignoble attaque informatique par
l'Empire Klingon qui paralyse tous les
systèmes électroniques l'équipage qui
jusque-là parlait anglais s'exprime
brusquement dans de multiples langues
terrestres et extraterrestres et plus
personne ne se comprend car jusque là
cette tour de Babel n'avait aucun
problème de communication grâce à des
implants qui permettent à chacun de
parler dans sa langue et de comprendre
la langue de l'autre un rêve pour
l'Union européenne et ses 24 langues et
pour votre serviteur certes c'est encore
la science-fiction mais le temps n'est
plus si éloigné où l'on pourra remiser
au placard la domination s'empartage de
l'horrible globiche qui permet tant bien
que mal aux Européens de se comprendre
souvent mal car englobish on dit ce que
l'on peut parce que l'on veut
contrairement à ce que ceux qui pensent
parler anglais les progrès fulgurants de
l'intelligence artificielle ont déjà
changé beaucoup de choses Google
Translate et d'autres applications
permettent ainsi de se faire comprendre
dans beaucoup de langues un rêve pour
les voyageurs et les outils de
traduction comme deeple sont de plus en
plus perfectionnés et rapides et le prof
de l'intelligence artificielle c'est
qu'elle apprend et se perfectionne un
logiciel trousing permet même de
substituer dans un film une langue par
une autre et de modifier le mouvement
des lèvres pour qu'il corresponde à la
langue parlée ce qui permet d'espérer
cursula faune versions arrêtera de nous
assommer avec ces vidéos exclusivement
en anglais et qu'elle pourra ainsi
s'adresser au 27 peuples qui composent
l'Union dans leur langue on peut donc
espérer que très rapidement tous les
sites de l'Union soit enfin disponibles
dans toutes les langues et qu'à terme
chacun pourra s'exprimer dans sa propre
langue en étant compris des autres le
jour où Bruxelles ressemblera à
l'entreprise et donc plus si loin ceux
qui ont des cheveux blancs à se faire ce
sont les interprètes et traducteurs qui
consomment une part non négligeable du
budget de fonctionnement de l'Union mais
c'est un prix peu élevé à payer pour en
finir avec le globish vive
l'intelligence artificielle
[Musique]
merci chers Jean 4mer qu'on pourra
peut-être dans quelques années entendre
dans toutes les langues du monde ça a
commencé à faire beaucoup déjà qu'avec
le français on saturé
Fabrice la rue l'intelligence
artificielle va tout révolutionner on ne
se rend pas compte à quel point ça va
changer notre vie et notre monde et on
le voit déjà avec le jeu vidéo parce que
le jeu vidéo c'est la porte ouverte au
métaverse avec le métaverse
l'intelligence artificielle intervient
donc ça va on n'imagine pas et
d'ailleurs pour les jeunes qu'on recrute
à l'heure actuelle la plupart des
métiers qui vont faire ils ne
connaissent pas encore ce qu'ils seront
dans 5 ou 10 ans qui viennent grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle ça c'est
formidable oui c'est ça on parle pas à
50 ans on est dans à 5 ou 10 ans
Laurence parrain vous vous anticipez ça
ici à Bruxelles parce que quand on voit
que les jeux vidéo qui existent depuis
50 ans vous y mettez à peine non il y a
un texte qui est en cours de négociation
c'est un long texte je crois qu'il y a
eu 30 déjà 30 réunions de de discussions
puisqu'il y a une communication
évidemment il faut aller vite que
l'intelligence artificielle ça va être
tout notre défi parce qu'il se passe
énormément de choses on voit le débat
avec Tchad JPY actuellement sur là
encore la transparence d'où sont les
sources
qui sont passés à côté c'est ce système
qui permet de lui poser une question et
il vous donne toute une dissertation et
avec beaucoup de débats qui souffrent
beaucoup alors je reviens à la dimension
culturelle aussi la question des droits
d'auteur parce que de quoi se nourrit
ces intelligences artificielles dès lors
qu'elles sont liées à la création on
apprend du Proust par cœur mais voilà
c'est pareil pour l'image donc il y a
beaucoup d'enjeux beaucoup de potentiels
notamment dans les domaines
scientifiques dans les domaines
techniques du jeu vidéo la médecine et
autres et puis après dès lors qu'on va
toucher aux industries culturelles il y
a beaucoup aussi de défis sur la
pérennité de la création et sur le droit
d'auteur alors Jean l'évoquais dans son
édito true think c'est quand même
sidérant ce qui va être possible de
faire grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle et ce doublage
en transformant la bouche et finalement
sur les personnages de films qui
pourront jouer au départ devant la
caméra en anglais et ensuite nous en
France et bien on les entendra en
français mais avec la bouche
faisant articulant articulant en
français ou en chinois ou en portugais
ou en espagnol genre c'est un rêve pour
vous c'est fantastique non mais c'est un
rêve même comme je le disais dans dans
l'édito on va enfin entendre Ursula
funderlion parler une autre langue que
l'anglais la présidente de la Commission
européenne Clotilde Goujard vous la
sentez émue par ces questions là Ursule
ou pas mais en tout cas l'intelligence
artificielle c'est vrai qu'il y a
contexte qui est en cours et parce que
l'idée aussi de faire attention à toutes
les dérives que ça peut amener
l'intelligence artificielle avec cette
idée là on parle aussi par exemple des
deepflex des images qui peuvent être
manipulées où on pourrait aussi créer
quelqu'un qui parle et qui dit des
choses qui l'a jamais dit et donc il y a
aussi pour faire un peu attention aussi
à ce qui pourrait sortir avec avec tous
ces textes c'est aussi à toutes les
discriminations qui peuvent émerger
parce que finalement toutes ces
traductions en fait elles se basent sur
des des textes des textes des données en
fait qui date de il y a plein d'années
et donc par exemple en anglais on va
peut-être dire the Joker et après la
traduction en français va faire un le
docteur et the north ça va passer à là
l'infirmière en tout cas ça va ça va ça
va masculiniser au féminiser des choses
basées sur finalement des clichés qu'on
a eu depuis des années où finalement
voilà des a prioris culturels et donc
l'idée est quand même de faire attention
et de mettre quelques règles autour de
tout ça pour éviter que bon on est des
des données qui soient très bien
de ce rapport sur les jeux vidéos qui
doivent trouver une place stratégique
ici à Bruxelles selon vous notamment sur
ces questions d'ingérence étrangères et
pourquoi pas avec une véritable
politique et des financements parce que
6 millions Fabrice la rue ça paraît un
petit peu court quand même vu de
Bruxelles merci Fabrice Larue je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
focus Entertainment merci Clotilde
Goujard de politico et Jean Quatremer
qui a toujours son Atari ou son nom je
suis sur le jeu
et David brasseur réalisé par Pascal
Simard à la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de la faute à l'Europe
[Musique]